all right worst of Nicolas Cage let's do
this
there's no need for an introduction you
know why you're here
Nicholas Cage is freakin crazy he's an
anomaly that no one can figure out as
shown last week he can be a legitimately
great actor but what everyone remembers
most about him are his performances that
are just batshit insane at 53 years old
with over 35 years in the picture
business
kgs already left behind a one-of-a-kind
legacy as he continues to pump out movie
after movie I'm sure there are a few
more gems in the future today however is
the mother of all worthless these of a
top 5 worst performances of
[Music]
Nicholas Cage number five Edward malice
in the wicker man
I know what you're all waiting for but
I'm not shown it no no not to be was an
alternate ending scene it wasn't in the
theatrical release I'm not doing it I'm
not doing I do
when police officer Edward malice get
the letter from his ex fiance about her
daughter going missing he travels to a
secluded Island to aid in the search
however upon arriving he is greeted with
a hostile community of mostly women who
obviously do not want him there slowly
he discovers disturbing rituals that
lead to a large harvest festival with a
girl he's searching for seemingly erased
from the island Edward is pulled deeper
and deeper into this unsettling isolated
society beside the insanity that happens
towards the end of this film cage is
just sort of bored in it yeah he's just
an unpleasant guy to be around
even before he goes to the island malice
gives off the impression of being a
boring lame character cage looks like he
couldn't give less of a crap through
most of the movie what what you just say
thankfully as the movie transitions into
its third act things start getting cagey
how did you burn how'd it get burned how
did you burn out of your burn like the
dogs no malice knocking out a few of
these ladies are some of the most
ridiculous sequences I've ever seen it's
hysterical and who could forget this
what's wrong sister it it's just the
best it's the worst but it's the best I
want more bear costume fights
we're sorely lacking in that area I
could only let these last few lines
speak for themselves
Julie we won't bring back your goddamn
honey Oh God also why is James Franco
and Jason Ritter at the end of this
movie it's just why why look at Franco
smile I can do a whole top 5 video based
on just his weird smiles alone alright
fine show it Oh
number four gallon an outcast Hayden
Christensen plus Nicolas Cage in a
period peace action movie what did you
expect when a Chinese king is murdered
by his oldest son his younger son who
was in line to be king and his daughter
go on the run from their crazed brother
while on the lam the pair run into a
war-weary Crusader named Jacob who
reluctantly agrees to help them later on
the man who raised him and fellow
Crusader Galan joins the fight and
together they defend the rightful king
from his older brother stolen royal
forces can you tell this was a Chinese
co-production full disclosure here Cage
is barely in this thing
he's front and center on all the
promotional material and his build
second but he's actually only in the
movie for what seems like maybe 15
minutes however when he is on screen it
sure is a treat you know I swore no to
your father if you haven't figured it
out already this movie freaking sucks I
did enjoy this scene though
I don't mind Sam
it's course rough and irritating
Christensen is probably even worse than
cages here they have some of the worst
English accents I've ever heard he was
out though they called the white dope I
am the white ghost but no one calls me
outlaw child not to my face
this comes off like cages bad take on a
Jack Sparrow type character I love blood
you want my blood
[Music]
I don't really know what he's trying to
do but at least this movie has some
entertainment value when he's on screen
otherwise it's a bore with nothing at
all that makes it stand out bad wig the
Nicolas Cage go together like peanut
butter and jelly like in this next
performance number three
Eddie King in arsenal this movie just
came out earlier this year and has Cage
playing a local kingpin with that wig
you cannot tell me he doesn't look like
Ron Burgundy Mikey and JP are brothers
who grew up very differently JP is a
successful local business owner while
his older brother Mikey has been in
prison several times and is finding it
difficult to stay on the right track
trying to make some money to support his
family
Mikey approaches the neighborhood crime
lord Eddy about working for him Eddie
and monkey have a history together but
that's all thrown out the window when
Mikey is taken hostage to extort money
from his well-off younger brother now JP
can trust no one and he tries to find
and save his troubled sibling this nose
wig and moustache combination is
legendary
he's full-on bad guy Nicolas Cage here
that entailed emotional outburst nobody
gives a shit about this guy nobody
I was started add random swearing in
lines only he could say J said that I
CAD said it cuz they fucking killed him
today alright video games were always a
pussy any King is a character who is as
over-the-top as possible he'd just leave
the old bad guy who was extremely over
emotional and has ties that go way back
with our protagonist by the way we get a
lot of slow-motion action shots in this
they last a while and sure slow-mo looks
cool but Arsenal pushes it a little too
far
it's now available on streaming so check
it out if you want to see how insane
cage still is after all these years
this character is suspiciously
comparable to an earlier role of cages
number two Eddie in deadfall this is a
very similar character to Eddie from
Arsenal and they even have the same name
but this Eddie is a Nicholas Cage
classic cages brother Christopher
Coppola directed this crime thriller
about a man named Joe who accidentally
kills his father during a sing Joe's
father's dying wish is that he recovered
things stolen from him by Joe's uncle
years earlier uncle Lou is a con man who
attempts to bring his nephew into his
perilous schemes but Joe in a dangerous
position
he must ring his uncle along while not
alerting him to his true intentions this
really seemed like a family affair as
even cages aunt Talia Shire makes a
cameo in this movie Adrian is a
bartender interesting
this is unfiltered cage his brother must
have let him loose because there is
absolutely no restraint in his
performance at all and admittedly it's
fantastic
[Music]
literally any time he talks it's like a
fever dream the any character here had
to have taken a lot out of the actor he
was that nuts in every second of every
scene he's in you really just have to
see it for yourself so here's another
clip okay show me okay okay
well hollow fucking knew your man die
Jokers Wow bullshit bullshit asshole
besides cages insanity deadfall is
actually pretty dull I recommend just
watching his scenes if he could find
them and the number one worst Nicolas
Cage performance is Peter low in
vampire's kiss so this is his worst
performance
but it's also at best performance in
fact I actually really really like this
Peter Lowe is a white-collar New Yorker
who routinely sleeps around with many
different women one night a woman named
Rachel bites him while in bed Peter
starts to think he's becoming a vampire
and begins acting like one despite not
physically changing simultaneously he is
constantly verbally abusive to his
secretary of work Alva who can't locate
a missing file this movie this character
this performance it's all fascinating in
[Applause]
all you have to do from a strange
accident to his absurd facial
expressions and exaggerated body
language Peter Lowe is one of the
weirdest main characters in a major
Hollywood production I personally sing
no matter how bad or over-the-top this
performance might be you can never take
your eyes off him his energy is
mesmerizing am I getting through to you
a lot I couldn't think of a more
horrible job if I wanted to and you have
to do it you have to or I'll fire you do
you understand the only thing I could
think of comparing this to is a zanier
version of American Psycho sort of
similar characters of similar ages with
similar white-collar jobs who both
descend into madness
the further the movie progresses this
movie is hilarious in a dark way but
when you see basically a live-action
cartoon character playing some of these
scenes out it can't help but laugh at
some of what transpires
says hashtag I enjoyed the hell out of
this movie and performance but maybe for
the wrong reason it's hard to tell in
the end though isn't that what Nic Cage
is all about worst is definitely a
relative term when it comes to
describing cages work he's not someone
you can really explain he has to be
experienced I encourage you to check out
a few of these performances and see for
yourself when Cage
over the top of worst he's
simultaneously at his best it's a
strange phenomenon that is mostly unique
to him I want to hear what you guys
think what is your least favorite
Nicholas Cage movie and/or performance
what do you want me to cover next in the
show leave a comment and let me know for
more content subscribe to my personal
channel youtube.com slash awesome walter
and follow me on twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future come back next week when we
cover the best of a legendary director
see you then okay there's one quite a
warm up winner now
powerful way map his man hears from
entire make you wanna feel I think I
could have been a really great Iron Man
I would almost keep them out at one
point with the flat on my raise I'm
still Nicolas came